al día siguiente de su reunión en kiev
con el presidente de volodymyr selenski
anthony blinken y austin expresaron su
confianza tanto el secretario de eeuu
como el jefe del pentágono indicaron que
ucrania puede ganar la guerra contra
rusia
creemos que los ucranianos pueden ganar
si cuentan con el equipo y el apoyo
adecuados
rusia ya ha fracasado en sus objetivos
bélicos porque el principal objetivo que
se propuso el presidente putin fue
someter a ucrania integrándola en rusia
para quitarles su soberanía e
independencia esto no ha sucedido y
claramente no sucederá nada
junto al presidente de lenski los dos
funcionarios anunciaron el retorno
gradual de la presencia diplomática
estadounidense en ucrania y lo más
importante un nuevo paquete de ayuda
militar de 700 millones de dólares
incluyendo 400 millones de dólares para
ayudar a los países de europa del este
que suministran armas al vecino ucrania
eeuu ha acelerado recientemente la
entrega de material militar a ucrania
las armas pesadas en particular para
resistir la ofensiva rusa que continúa
en todo el país y que se concentra
especialmente en el este y sur del país
en mariupol las fuerzas rusas siguen
bombardeando el vasto complejo
metalúrgico de alto fiscal donde se
atrincheran los últimos combatientes
ucranianos pero también casi 1000
civiles atrapados
hace un mes y medio que nuestros hijos
no ven la luz del sol
el lunes el ministerio de defensa ruso
volvió a anunciar un alto el fuego en la
devastada ciudad portuaria para permitir
la evacuación de combatientes y civiles
ninguno de los intentos anteriores de
crear un corredor humanitario el
mariupol ha tenido éxito hasta ahora